on this episode I tell a lovely lady
from Atlanta to listen to 21 savage
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 237 of
the ask gary vee show big big big big
big day as in fact Kyler know we don't
really really edit this show but put it
up right now I'll talk over it for a
couple seconds just The Wall Street
Journal article a very big acquisition
by now the holding company Vayner X that
owns vaynermedia over here and now pure
well or the gallery over there pure well
being one of the three or four most
important women modern media companies
and where's vaynermedia is an agency and
buys media does creative pure Wow is a
publisher it is literally like a
modern-day People magazine so I'm very
excited about that we are going to do
some serious damage and I hope you reach
out to pure well sign up for the
newsletter if that kind of content
interests you pass it on to your
significant others that may have
interest in that content and and and I'm
excited about it's the biggest
acquisition like well we get away into
shell all right fine hello hello this is
Gary Vaynerchuk and you were on the show
hey Gary how are you I'm well who is
this baby Gannon Candice how's it going
it's going excellent sir how is it going
for you super well were you from uh Lana
Georgia very nice I love Atlanta are you
big 21 savage fan 20 light I don't know
what that it we just moved here in the
last year so tell me what that is I will
go check it out
21 savage is a rapper from Atlanta I
think you'll like him check out his
music oh cool I will look at up ok cool
what's your question
so I'm in between I have a bunch of
opportunities and I don't know which fun
and I know your philosophy of work work
work and I'm trying to figure out how to
fit it all in but I find a cabinet
designer and I have the opportunity to
basically go work for a very high-end
firms and continue to do if and try to
continue to do my own stuff and become a
rap like all of these opportunities are
coming all at once and I'm trying to
figure out the best way she found
Simo without base Borneo suffocating
myself yes exactly burning out so let's
work backwards and this is what
everybody needs to do it's so easy to
make decisions when you have clarity on
what you want to happen and what you
want to happen is always short term and
long term so talk to me about what would
you like to happen in the macro from a
financial work-life balance and the kind
of things that you want I mean it's just
choices right and it's like life is very
simple like because I chose that I want
to own the New York Jets my work-life
balance is not as good as it would be if
I was okay with where I am now right I
don't know if you saw the news of the
pure Wow deal I wouldn't be buying this
big media company because I'm rich
enough already if I wanted to just be
rich right no I want to buy a football
team thus I have to be on the offense at
41 years old like I have nothing at I'm
20 got it so the biggest narrator so
help me understand the financial
situation of all of this like do you
want to make lots of money like your
financial situation do you have to make
the money like our where are you in your
life with family like how much vacation
time do you want to do and where do you
want to end up like what's like work
backwards
give me some day back so right now we're
basically an empty nester both of our
both of our children are in college
that's huge and you a lot of flexibility
yep yes so and ideally like my big
picture scheme as I would like to get
into house flipping and doing Airbnb and
stuff like that because again being a
cabinet designer I look at all these
people who flip houses around here and
go I know I could do that so much better
I love that and I think I think it would
be a great market and told the real
estate market you just got to not get
caught of when you've got momentum going
in two or three years of having too much
inventory that you're sitting on and
then the market gets soft so as long as
there's not a collapse of the housing or
Wall Street market you're going to
cruise and as long as you're
conservative and not don't get too big
for your bridges as you're doing and
buying and flipping don't overextend
yourself even in a crash as long as
you're playing with house money you'll
be fine right and that's that's part of
my problem in looking at the big picture
is right now we're a little bit in debt
it was if I again bust my tail for the
day out here I could get a completely
out of debt in the end so I hear
let's let's let's start right there
immediately do that come like I can tell
by your energy and your vibe work your
face off for the next year and get
yourself out of debt take all the jobs
do all the things pumped everything
leisure right now do that that's just a
good idea right I mean it and then I
mean it oh I believe I know and I'm by
the way we only had one year is nothing
d-roc and I were just sitting in a hotel
in Vegas saying like hey this dailyvee
thing is gonna be big it was five
seconds ago
that was one year ago like one year goes
real fast
debt compounds there's no reason to have
it if you're that close and your energy
feels so good that you want to do the
work anyway
it's like eat that crow for one-year
period no doubt a hundred percent and
like be smart like speed up the process
to nine months by not buying you know $8
lettuce instead of $6 lettuce and like
flip some [ __ ] in your garage like all
that stuff like just make that your core
number one thing definitely do that
that's number one
ya know I was waiting for you to drop
the eBay thing because I up selling my
husband I'm like he's really good he
like some old-school cars and stuff like
that and he knows that stuff and using
like the back of a fan and I'm like okay
you need to like figure that out like
fun yessing doors and stuff like that
okay though yeah so that's my big
picture thing is trying to figure out
how to get there and also because once
we get out of debt I'm trying to figure
out how to balance that like do I go
take out one no I need tell you let me
tell you what I would do let me tell
that I do the housing markets been good
for long enough here's my advice it as
if you were my sister crush your debt go
crazy your husband if he's deeply
knowledgeable about automobiles will be
blown away and you live in Atlanta which
means year why garage sales and things
of that nature cuz a warm weather he
he's by accident gonna make twenty
thirty forty thousand dollars it's gonna
happen I'm telling you right now that's
based on if he works like I do which is
all in right if he works less than only
five thousand set at 30 thousand clear
your debt year one year to 2018 work
your face off and save money right save
and then whatever you saved let's say
you've got $48,000
great that means that's your down
payment and then get a mortgage on the
wreck rest for your first flip got it
right 24 months of eating [ __ ] to be
able to eat caviar for the rest of your
life yeah because that's my big picture
as I want to be able to when
quote-unquote retire and I say that very
loosely because I don't want to work for
a paycheck anymore I just want to work
because the bank we're best way to do
that is to go extreme everybody's trying
to drag that out over eight years and
take a vacation here make 5,000 on eBay
instead of 20,000 work one of the jobs
not two of the jobs the best way to do
it is you never promise tomorrow even
though I talk about patience I'm aware
that you're not promised tomorrow when
you can do something do it
so crush the next 24 months clean debt
get 10 15 20 50 80 thousand dollars in
savings whatever it ends up being that
is your deposit get the mortgage for
whatever else you can and do the flip
and if that doesn't get you the house
that you want for your first flip then
eat another pile of [ __ ] in 2019 and now
you've got 90 thousand dollars for the
deposit and then you put that down got
it yeah yeah that's why I'm working it
up there so it's it's put its clouds and
dirt it's going all-in for the next 24
months and not being glamorous so that
you can be glamorous for the rest of the
way the problem is everybody hedges and
then a net they're half pregnant the
whole 50 years know and that's what I
don't want to be and I'm like you I'm
about the same age and I just like I'm
like okay no it's like full speed ahead
now because I'm just like I don't want
to wake up in 20 years or ten years ago
us we're still here annually but I have
hitting me all three jobs
stop don't watch a single thing don't go
anywhere work for next 24 months you
will win captain all right love you see
ya all right thank you sir bye that was
really good no seriously this Colin show
is gonna be rich like that guys I'm
telling you I see some of your comments
I'm reading you guys all the time I
understand some of the clunkiness chris
has got his call game down better there
you know I understand but I'm telling
you and we probably need to do the audio
it'd be probably really smart so I have
to hold the dimpling though I do think
that's a little funny and I think that
just might be a whole thing yeah I'm
ready um this Kong show is going to be a
big
are you happy are they having that yeah
yeah yes Jesse this is Gary Vee I'm your
on the askgaryvee show
oh [ __ ]
what up Jess oh my god what is going on
man what are you from I'm from Southern
California my here Mojave love it
what can I help mommy desert love it
okay now all right so here's here's the
thing so I've been trying everything out
I've been doing I just failed I did
marketing I did some startup business
some small stuff you know I've been
sitting in the same job for the last six
years growing speaking out mentors been
doing my thing I've been trying out the
eBay thing and I just got hit yesterday
with my first couple sales so I'm super
stoked on that and thankful for that man
first [ __ ] dude I'm [ __ ] stoked right
now no you know what miss before I ask
the question I just want to say thank
you for everything you do man I preach
him I throw your name out there anytime
somebody stops five seconds to listen to
me say everything you offer is fricking
huge man my brother's friends co-workers
I'm like Gary Vaynerchuk they're like
Gary Gary who them I think them up right
now follow everything he does
thanks anyways I'm doing all this stuff
I'm everywhere right now and I'm trying
to figure out what what is the next step
I mean I'm trying printing anything and
I'm not in it
you know I want to make money I want to
be core so there's no doubt about yeah
I'll be hard not chasing them exactly
look you don't want to behave like
nobody yeah not everybody wants to buy
the Jets right and by the way by the way
let me actually this against Colin shows
gonna be great if I like if I want it
like if I didn't love what I do
all 19 hours a day then I wouldn't be
talking [ __ ] about buying the Jets I got
lucky that the thing that I love most is
building big businesses right like if I
loved you know being an architect more
than anything in life and that's what I
gravitated to Legos and drawing when I
was 6 7 9 12 13 instead of selling
lemonade and selling flowers and selling
baseball cards then I would just be
talking about becoming the greatest you
know architect of all time and that
wouldn't make me trillions no one made
me successful and rich and I get it but
like or there
honestly like if I was wired like by the
way and this is why you like me so much
I if I didn't have the DNA of a Salesman
and an entrepreneur I would be a
guidance counselor right like I love I
live for deep bro do you know how much
money I leave on the table by giving you
this by doing what I'm doing right now
I'm leaving a lot of a man and and and
by the way it's not because I'm such a
great guy
it's because hearing you say that in the
beginning of this call is a greater high
for me than any deal I've ever closed in
business and that's not even close by
the way having another human being tell
you that you're having a positive impact
on their life I promise you this you're
not coming to my funeral because I made
one point seven trillion dollars in my
career
you're coming my funeral because I might
have made you 1,700 more dollars and
tweaked you in a place where you had 49
more years of happiness right dude
honestly it's very simple to answer a
question so I went in a little bit of
rant what do you like when you're not
working
build a business around that all right
like what do you want like I gotta tell
you right now this whole Vayner sports
thing I'm getting scared I might shut it
all down
I'm in love with it having these
football players set at vaynermedia John
Toth yesterday offensive lineman center
for Kentucky Gonia he's gonna be on the
Packers in six months it's the weirdest
thing
Alvin Kamara is gonna rush for 137 yards
on a Sunday and I'm gonna quit man
that's my dude like it's crazy and I
love it and watching a Jays happiness
he's not going to make anywhere close to
as much money as he did at vaynermedia
but watching the happiness in his heart
like what do you like surfing what do
you like like like t-shirts what do you
like hip-hop like what do you like I'm
being that I like to be honest is you
know for a while it's like an extreme
sport thing but now what it is is
building people like that's what I like
I like doing other people
salut are and I and I think you know
this I'm very scared of the life coach
business because I think people are
ripping people off so as long as you
know you as long as you feel good about
it like here's an idea
what about starting a club like what
about what about like dude there's so
much [ __ ] you can do let me throw you
rogue ass [ __ ] why don't you get a job
at night at a rest
where you tell the owner that you want
to work as a bartender because you want
to start a club in his restaurant or her
restaurant every Wednesday night for
aspiring entrepreneurs or for people
that want to live better lives
so the exchanges I am way overqualified
for this job I'm going to work here
three nights a week and I'm going to
meet people that come here and I'm going
to start a club in your restaurant and
then what you're going to do is once you
test out what a club and a group
together at a restaurant looks like you
may go then get investors or buy your
own or save money or sell everything on
eBay and get your own like do [ __ ] is
the answer do you understand
right totally and on that the craziest
[ __ ] about that which just that is this
today at 11:30 I actually orchestrated
three weeks ago starting the club at my
business the company that I work at in
the first day of the club start today
we're going into leadership I'm going to
help do my best help and learn from
other people with the company who want
to be bigger who want to be better want
to do more not just the works can I ask
you a question I'm not off of that what
just happened when do you think the
world's gonna realize that I'm actually
a genie from a different planet I think
that's not freaks me out when stuff like
so cool anyway listen listen my man keep
focusing on this I like the vibe of your
voice that's one of the reasons I kind
of like I'm very big on tone and energy
that's why the calling show is gonna be
better because when I read it I don't
have the tone I can tell the goodness
coming out of your mouth I could feel it
let me tell you this it sounds like
you're fairly young how old are you 29
2010 patience brother keep doing good
keep bringing people value and don't
think about what's in it for you what's
in it for you will happen when you were
purely pushing to bring people value
[ __ ] just happens oh yeah and you've got
time brother
you've got five years do me a favor
don't try to charge a thousand bucks
ahead or 500 bucks a month do this just
keep bringing value and I'm telling you
for five years online offline random
just keep bringing value it will work
itself out you got a lot of time to cash
in on doing that good move after Amadou
sorry mother take care you do fine
you're like a muffled brother and called
on my mother for a second
anyway I'm really enjoying this format
yeah
let me say how well he's doing that oh
whoops Instagram Instagram Instagram
what's up uh guys watching the show
right now on YouTube and Facebook if
you're not following me on Instagram
there's a lot going on down there
over the last 30 days it's gotten
ridiculous it's got super ridiculous
maxumcorp you can see really good is
this Jason great right look Jason this
is Gary Vaynerchuk and you were on the
show are you serious I'm dead serious
Jason OH where are you from I live in
New Jersey oh oh
Jersey baby I love East Brunswick you
said he's Windsor Oh winsome yeah I know
it I know it I know it how you doing I'm
good man
oh my god just watching you Oh like I
got a call what can I answer for you
okay man so I'm a website designer I've
been freelancing for about 15 years now
I don't want it all been good um I want
to do Mitch beats website design for
different you know avenues yes and I'm
trying to build my portfolio but it's
like you know the competition is so big
so I'm trying to figure out how do i
monetize that and and I want to teach
younger people as well to do it and
coding things like that and provide jobs
because I'm good at what I do it for
like designing but how do I uh so let's
start first things first before you
start teaching other people how to do it
we need you to be ridiculously
successful so that you can afford to
teach people to do it otherwise you're
gonna charge them too much to teach them
to do it and then you'll break got it
yeah so let's start with this you want
to build websites in a specific niche or
just in general you know that everybody
in the world needs a website and that
the long tail of niche stuff it's a lot
easier to get Joe the Plumber to build
his website than Pepsi is that what
you're saying yeah good yeah so how much
do you want to charge to build
somebody's website that's a small
business or an entrepreneur or an
influencer
what's your what's a nice range it nice
rate is about three point dollars I like
the subscription-based like you know
twenty five hours a month so I'm like
you know I like like in a laying out
little and for a while a lot of
barbershops and so were you are you are
you so you want to do the whole I'll
turn you 500 bucks to build your website
and then 25 bucks a month maintenance
recurring so you have recurring revenue
in case they need you and that's how you
scare right okay so are you building on
top of WordPress and Squarespace and
things of that nature
Shopify that's why you're able to great
my man I'm gonna give you a piece of
advice that is a hundred percent and the
only reason you won't be successful is
because you're not hungry enough and
you're too lazy you ready yeah good I
want you go to Instagram are you
watching me on Instagram yeah good I
want you to stop watching me on
Instagram I want you to start this
process and I want you to do it for five
to seven hours a day
you ready yeah I want you to search a
hashtag I want you to go to the search
up top I want you to search grocery
store local butcher plumber when you
search it they'll be a hashtag and then
I want you to spend 25 minutes hitting
every picture that has the hashtag
plumber and see if it's the account of a
plumbing company or a plumber who is a
small business I want you then click the
URL that is linked to that person's
account and look at their website if
they have a good website leave him alone
if the website is [ __ ] I want you to go
back into Instagram and hit the top
right corner triple buttons on that
person's profile and send them a message
and say yo this is me I'm the best at
small business website design your
website is not on point I've got to
think that's 500 bucks up front 25 bucks
a month and you will crush it and you
will return on that investment in one
day let alone one year because your
website will be stronger that you're
linked to on Instagram and you'll
convert better and I want you to do that
for 5 to 7 hours every single day which
means that your message between 70 and
250 people a day and you will do a lot
of business then your thank you then I'm
on it right now
down on it right now bottle up and a few
much and I'll let you know done thank
you you're welcome
yeah no you're just gonna say with the
best clever call all right there's a
little bit shorter episode of the
askgaryvee show but clearly we are I
mean ah I don't know what you guys think
this was so much cleaner like think you
could feel it right we know what this
looks like
question of the day what is your small
business solution this doesn't answer
for everybody but I want to get some
small business talk are you a small
business do you provide services for
small business think about what's your
small business world solution thoughts
feelings stories history how do you roll
with small business you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering
[Music]